là tout de suite à la luna blatgé parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chinois le public ce soir j'ai un prêtre
dans une fête foraine on dirait qu on
dirait qu'on ne saurait connaître un
gros bide aux audi va aller on se
retrouve bien sûr il y aura des autos
tamponneuses à la olive à la diablesse
on va jouer donc à d'autres je sais la
luna bluff la roue numérique va désigner
à chronique alors je vais donner une
affirmation
ça peut être une vraie info ou une
fausse info médias la personne va devoir
décider si je dis la vérité ou si je
mens ou par de parvenir à savoir si je
bluff ou pas vous pourrez éliminer une
personne autour de la table d'accord la
personne qui restera la fin des il y
aura un garçon et une fille qui devront
se déguiser en jacquouille la fripouille
et dame ginette d'accord en fait je peux
recevra les visiteurs
cet après midi jean luc lemoine a fait
ses courses dans un supermarché avec une
perruque de louis saez
vrai ou faux faux pourquoi tout bon
genevois préfèrent voir d'abord il est
pas très perruque noire puis la perruque
qui ne rentraient pas les gens
aujourd'hui qu'on aime bien vrai fait
qu'elle physique on l'a toujours fait
dans cette émission et c'est très bien
accueilli et jean-luc vous pouvez
éliminer quelqu'un maintenant c'est moi
j'aime bien quand jean-luc élimine les
gens est limité car jean-luc ps qui
donne toujours les bonnes réponses
donc voilà c'est ça fait de la peine et
puis gilles parce que j'en ai l'hymne 2
non non on y va j'ai une photo
ah non d'ailleurs c'est pour vous j'ai
une photo de michel drucker torse nu en
train de faire de la musculation
j'ai une photo de michel drucker torse
nu en train de faire de la musculation
vrai ou faux vous connaissant oui vrai
donc c'est vraiment oui je le pense
vraiment pourquoi me connesson parce que
je pense que vous pouvez avoir ce genre
de photo ja que vous pour avoir je
voudrais avoir vrai comme ça je peux
l'éliminer
c'est vrai qu'ils vous aident à huawei
ses bagages
c'était il ya deux semaines ça soit il
est pas beau michel regards paniqués au
tour de michel alors vous allez vider
qui thierry moreau on est là on en est
on en est ah ouais euh on en est à vous
à elle donc elle a dit ça on est
traditionnel terminée voilà mais non
c'est pas ça oui là j'ai une photo de
michel drucker torse nu en train de
faire des mélanges de sang s'est déjà
montrée c'est dommage a les bonnes
j'ai une vidéo j'y verrai avec la coupe
c'est scandaleux
mais la personne qui a fait ses filles à
l'entrée du studio les agents de
securitas la coupe de cheveux et le
phrasé de jacquouille la fripouille
vrai ou faux alors ça énorme à la grue
lama la grh lavalas gros sel dits oui il
faudra éliminer deux personnes c'est
vrai c'est une question qui nous est
chère migraient ouais ouais ouais je
condamne le gard en vidéo postroff
rencontrer les gus mais furtivement à
l'entrée donc je me suis pas
complètement du compte il avait le
phrasé regardons
[Rires]
alors septième affirmation il existe une
photo de virgile hanouna de cyril
hanouna 6 un slip dans un casino à las
vegas à ces thématiques - ouais c'est
pour vous n'en fait pas assez pour vous
oui c'est vrai il est facile celle là
elle est facile c'est vrai et bien sûr
mais aussi dans la foulée on n'a pas la
photo je ne peux pas le vérifier ou non
quel dommage
ouais si oui ou non il ya pas photo y'a
pas la photo voilà n'est pas le maire
vous soyez deux personnes qui vont se
met donc en jacquouille autour de la
table aller en dame ginette alesi 20
michèle et gilles bas va très bien merci
jusqu'où on a complètement oublié jean
michel maire et gilbert n'a c'est vrai
ça fait une heure ça fait quand même une
heure qu'ils sont
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va tout le monde sait ça va
extrêmement bien et quand je vous vois
je me suis dit on aurait pu les oublier
jusqu'à la fin non mais ça fait plaisir
vous soyez la paix vous savez que vous
êtes extrêmement séduisant en eau
non mais je vous jure isabelle rien
l'habille ah oui moi je trouve très beau